oh okay I just saw Mary Poppins returns
okay where do we even start with this
all right my thoughts on the original
Mary Poppins let's do that get that out
of the way love the original Mary
Poppins I think it's a classic it has my
all-time favorite movie moment that's
when the father is walking to his job
he's gonna get fired it's just an
amazing scene beautifully shadow
dialogue wonderful music the movie
itself uh even though I mean a lot of
it's for little kids don't get me wrong
there are a lot of things about II it's
a very simple story but but there's many
kind of adult elements to it that makes
it kind of timeless and the songs are
timeless and the characters are
surprisingly really well done even stuff
like dipping Deitz dick Van Dyke's
terrible accent he's still so likable in
this and it's a spectacle of a movie I
mean it's one of those where when a song
sequence gets going you kind of want to
keep going it's just a rush and it's a
great mix of visual effects and
practical offended all this stuff it's a
great magical journey that's just about
family trying to grow closer together
the father with the children um a very
simple story you know even back then
those were kind of done before but still
had a lot of heart a lot of charm live
intelligence absolutely love it um now
we have this one made a cuts decades
later I think everyone agrees it doesn't
need to exist even watching the trailer
people are like cool will be neat to see
this kind of stuff again and I'll first
get out of the way who will probably
like this movie if you have little kids
maybe five or six I think you're risking
it a little bit if you go older but if
you have like little little kids this is
totally fine and it's kind of really
geared towards them we're the first film
was death
for little little kids but had a lot of
these adult elements - and this one
tries but but we'll get to that mainly
like when a song sequence happens this
is not like an updated Mary Poppins this
is very much trying to capture the
original it's funny that this is a
sequel because it feels very much like a
remake like unbelievably like a remake
but you know but they sing different
songs and they say different words at
this scene that looks eerily similar to
the first one and came along at the same
time in a bit ba-ba-ba-ba uh with that
said if you're just looking for that
nostalgia of Mary pop I love Mary
Poppins but I'm like I got the movie I'm
good I can just watch that one again but
there's a lot of people that want to
relive it like a lot of people saw the
new Beauty and the Beast and they loved
it because they love the nostalgia I get
it
cool you know it's this is perfect for
that because there's a lot of remember
last time oh hey remember when you said
this well is it like quote from the
first movie yes but with this new spin
that's not really much of a spin it's
just tying two different words but but
it's that same idea it's it's like Mary
Poppins comfort food I guess you saw it
before if you liked it you know and you
wanted to see something super similar
you'll get it this is very much that
kind of movie and I feel like there are
gonna be people that like this movie
just because it's cool to see Mary
Poppins again and with slightly
different problems but they just want to
go back to this world and they want the
kind of these new characters and such
which again are like the old characters
but okay okay so if you're just going in
for a nostalgic value I get it like I
always make the comparison to the second
Sin City which is a lot of the same but
I love that world I love those
characters and I it's not like you're
less of a person or you're missing
something it's just you're going for the
nostalgia and that's cool that's
wonderful with that said this movie
starts out and and goes really bad
imagine you're watching the first movie
again except they just suck out the
freshness of it and the surprise of it
and the spot and eighty of it because
they're just recreating a lot of the
first film again and then throw in chase
scenes and a villain because Mary
Poppins really needed a villain
yeah we're doing this shit and not just
a villain an early 90's villain first
just take a wild guess from the trailers
over there who the villain in this movie
it's the bank this evil guy who owns the
bank and the movie is set up so that
it's years later and Jane and Michael
are grown up Jane and Michael are the
best part of this movie I'm just gonna
say right now wonderfully acted I
suppose the acting and this was pretty
good but they especially I have no
problem believing it's them they feel
like the only characters that have kind
of evolved that they've actually grown
up there they're a little different and
I love that but with that said they get
in this problem because Michael's wife
died some time ago and she handled all
the finances well now the house is gonna
be foreclosed out or is gonna be
repossessed and they need to find these
they don't have the money and they need
to find this the sheet of paper that
shows that the father gave them some
shares that'll make them safe first of
all your kid is already totally in this
right talking about like shares and
going to banks and stuff like that like
the in the original like the bank talk
was meant to be confusing that was part
of the fun like no kid would understand
it but this is like no this is a big
part of the story there's like a lot of
bank talk in this so I hope you're
excited for that so so they go and
they're like well maybe if we go to the
bank yeah we can see that they have you
know the information they're written
down but the evil bank owner
mmm-hmm he wants that house so he looks
and says oh that's where there's no
recorded information well I'll look for
it further take care crumbles it up
throws it in the fire what was on that
it was he's a bad man we're doing this
shit and not only that in the climax cuz
Mary Poppins has a climax now they're
rushing like on these bikes doing like
BMX tricks which is really weird
although they're all they're not Chimney
Sweeps anymore now they're the lighters
you know they light the lamps totally
different they're rushing to race the
clock because the banker said I'll give
them to midnight popopo looking at his
watch and everything and there's a chase
scene where they drag it to the bank and
then they're trying to get to the clock
to turn back time you know the stop Big
Ben turn off all the lights in there and
then push back the the giant hand
Amelia Pratt here is here is the
immediate problem Mary Poppins it's not
this kind of storage because if it was
this kind of story why doesn't she just
fly up and do it herself
well she does eventually spoilers I'm
sorry it's just so stupid I don't give a
fuck she flies up while birdies risk at
Nippert sorry jack
totally different character jack goes up
there hanging on a limb he's gonna fight
some goddamn big band he's gonna fall
over and like his his life he's trying
to push and he's hanging on Christ I
know goddamn fuckin do it I'm seeing the
Angels uncle kill me and Mary Poppins
comes in with Rose like I can do this
it's like why his wife they're trying to
put a logical story to this that's
already so illogical and so rehash from
the early 90s but then to make it even
better once they see the time has you
know the time hasn't hit that yet uh you
know Jane and Michael are going in and
the big bad banker he's the doors and
the bankers go with the lawyers I'm
sorry because they're evil too they go
to the door they tried to keep it closer
to kick it in as like what is this this
is not married Papa Mary Poppins the
climax was a dude
walking to the bank to face his destiny
he was gonna stand up for its kids even
though it was gonna cost him his job a
lot like his his legacy was in this bank
everything was in this Bank but he found
out his kids were more important and he
was going there and me and he stood
proud for his kids and then it all
happened he laughed and he found his
inner child and then the so did the
banker and so that's the climax and it
was beautifully does artistically done
looked phenomenal this not only had such
a scene at the end but imagine the of
the merry-go-round scene in the first
one because they do that again
oh sorry it's it's a pot there on this
little shine apart so it's totally
different but still animated animals
flying around they sing a song they sing
a song with weird words that are long
and complicated and it's just that but
just imagine in the merry-go-round scene
in the first one if like the Fox it's
like you know Oh get away from the dog
and they just turns to the camera with
an evil smile and then after
supercalifragilistic
supercalifragilistic expialidocious
the Fox like just starts stealing
everyone's shit loads it onto a truck
and goes Moo ha ha ha ha and drives off
and kidnaps yeah I don't know Michael
KITT Nats Michael and Jane and the
others are trying to rescue him you know
other little merry-go-round the horses
and the it gets dark and the florist is
like trying to eat them too and the Fox
is going ha ha ha and then they just
wake up from this terrible nightmare it
turns out it was symbolic of the evil
bank they want to take away that's this
movie that's what this movie does Christ
I mean it is this is so fascinating
because this is trying to recreate the
magic and the wonder of Mary Poppins and
throughout a good chunk of it even
though I wasn't getting into it I'm like
this is uh this is an understandable
attempt I can see why someone would
bring their family to this and why
someone would enjoy and stuff but then
you try to add this threat this threat
of these evil people bear MARY POPPINS
weirdly enough doesn't need a bad guy
did you even goddamn watch saving mr.
banks that's what it was about it was
taking out the bad guy it was making it
so that they were just people the focus
of the first movie was these two kids
trying to you tried to reconnect with
her father and the father trying to
teach them not to grow up too fast you
know to let them be kids I mean I mean
that the Michael's only like I don't
know five or something like that URI
wants to open him in a count and he's
trying to teach like what to do is my
you try it say no you can give you can
give to the bird lady there you know and
again just coming back to saving mr.
banks
god damn it Disney you made this movie
you you should know what it's about
where it you know Disney would just sit
down and they just play you know feed
the birds they'd be like that that's
what it's all about that that's Mary
Poppins and that is what it's all about
and it's beautiful and it's simple and
that's why it works and that's why
people are still watching it yours later
it's not about trying to save this
goddamn house from this evil banker you
idiot you idiots are you nuts so so
here's what's so funny I was watching a
good chunk of this movie
honestly like totally fine I'm watching
it like okay this this just feels like
repay I mean every day it starts out
showing the house in disarray and then
the kids are unhappy the kids you could
you know if you're to tell me what's the
personality of a girl the same as the
two boys they're all identical they're
like you doing Louie but but they're all
acting up and they find out the big bad
bank wants to come in and take the house
away and you know and Michael has a song
about how things are and how they used
to be and are you know crumbling down
and then Mary Poppins comes in saying
hey nice she needs to save the banks
children again pretty much you know and
and their other kids do that the three
kids cuz Jane and Michael are the banks
kids
Jane has to go on another political
March because again first movie and you
know they're just like and of course
Michael doesn't know about
well I guess what why is he like kind of
weirdly resistant to this this was the
nanny that he just associates with like
saving his life but now he thinks that
they were kids are they imagined a witch
at first I thought it was kind of cool
cuz I'm like okay I kind of like that
cuz like did they what was real it
wasn't but big shock at the end it's all
real um and they so then they go and
it's like well let's do bath time again
you're just taking and Achor that the
kids don't like and you turn it into
this magical adventures and a pajama
game and then they run into Bert number
two which is played by a limo l who is
playing a guy named Jack Y for hippies
Bert's son or like he just knew Bert or
something but he's playing Bert and it's
just like in the original comes a crumb
but instead of going in a chalk drawing
they go inside this this china pot which
at first again is kind of cool because
there's like everything's kind of shaped
like a china pot you know they have like
the little cracks in there and stuff
like man that's kind of clever um but
then they just go into the
supercalifragilistic stuff again they
just make up new words and what's a
shame the songs in this are actually
good they're they're well written smart
songs and the lyrics especially I mean
just every beat has a word to it it's a
weird word and it's one of those I can
see like kids watching it and trying to
recreate those songs you know like
United States Canada Mexico Panama like
they have songs like that and I can see
kids trying to go in and lay your
recreate them and stuff like that but
all you're thinking about is well that's
like supercalifragilistic is beyond us
yeah well that's like they feed the
birds well that's like this eh and after
they get out then they you know after
the animated scene with a chase scene by
these wolves who are symbolic of the
bankers yeah and like I said uh they go
to bed but they don't want to go to bed
because they're thinking of their laws
mothers so she sings a song in bed like
the other time she sang a song in bed to
try and calm them down and then well
what else what else well I just think
what happens in married Poppins whether
they go to the tea party on the day yep
that's right
they have another
winning this played by Meryl Streep
doing this weird uh I think it's Russia
I'm not sure it is some sort of accent
and it again it's a cute idea that the
house flips upside down just this room
flips upside down and they sing a little
song about it's cute but I'm just
thinking about Edwin and I love to laugh
and the song sounds very similar to that
so then they leave and they have this
run-in at the bank identify key at the
bank and that happened right after - yes
it did and they don't get along there
and they're thrown out and the father is
very angry about what happened at the
bank and then they get lost in the night
like in the first film uh they got lost
at the night but they come across Bert
number two who has his whole crew of
other chimney sweets I'm sorry lamp
lighters and they do all these you know
acrobatics and stuff which are cool
they're neither that the BMX bike tricks
again we're a little weird but you know
it's still impressive they're really
they're doing all the stuff but all
you're thinking of it's goddamn step in
time so instead of saying man this is
such a rush this is so new I can't wait
to see where guy just wanted to keep
going forever step in time goes on for
like eons but I never want to end it's
amazing I'm just thinking when is this
gonna wrap up because I just want to
watch step in time I just wanna watch it
when it was fresh and new and then yeah
you just get to this stupid climax where
they're trying to you know race against
the clock literally to get you know that
this piece of paper to the bank and the
big bad Bank or you know wants to throw
it in the fire
I mean it's Christ dammit dammit it
pisses me off because a lot of people
are like saying it yeah this is kind of
its own thing and I respect that it's uh
in my opinion it's so clearly not every
moment I'm thinking back to the original
on thing in the original did that the
original did this they did in the exact
same order even fly a kite now it's a
whole lot to a boil fly a balloon it's
the exact same thing the only part that
I felt was actually kind legitimate ly
like oh that's kind of warm is Angela
Lansbury has a cameo at the end who I
I feel like they were originally gonna
get Julie Andrews for that but um but I
don't know I know she has a problem
singing now too so I mean maybe that's
part of it I have no idea but yeah
Angela Lansbury is there at the end she
still yeah heart just melt when you see
her it's like oh my god she's so great
but yeah it's still the exact same thing
and then the wind changes and but
instead of the windmill this time it's a
door opening so completely different the
story evolves and Mary Poppins takes off
again that's it's really not a spoiler
because like everything if you've seen
the first film you've seen this film but
it's a sequel it's so bizarre and it's
such a shame because I feel like there
was a lot of talent and effort that went
into this uh and you know again maybe
maybe people will really get a lot out
of it there are a lot of critics are
liking it I if the theater I saw it it
was dead empty but I saw like on a
Wednesday night but yeah I don't know
how audiences are gonna react but but I
will say the focus is definitely on the
little kids and when they try to do this
stuff for the adults it's nothing I mean
it's like singing about the mother being
gone okay like just they do that once
and then they do it again and that's
about it for singing about you know if
we're discussing the lost of a loved one
I really thought that was gonna be like
the focus of this I thought it was gonna
be more on the wife being gone but it's
you know it's mentioned in passing in
the beginning he I guess he sings a
little song about it but that's a little
bit more of how things are in disarray
but it's like and then you just kind of
ignore the kids except for one scene
where they say I miss my mom they'll
really don't go through any like loss
they never act like they're going
through loss anyway and then the father
has a meltdown and the kids sing to them
and it's all better I mean by the end
you kind of forget there is even a dead
mother in it which is weird cuz it's a
Disney film they always like to hammer
that in um so man man man like I said
this is definitely a movie
for younger younger little little kids
the nothing is really in terms of tone
nothing is updated and if you're gonna
do this if you're gonna do this
incredibly pointless sequel update it
add some new stuff don't just change the
location or change a character's name
just really do some new stuff with it
and some callbacks are fine like having
the house flip upside down or the room
flip upside down and they have to walk
through an inn sing a little song it's
like okay what are two of those are fine
but when it's the whole movie I'm just I
could not wait for it to be over and
it's not that it was like torturous
because like I said that the they're all
good actors the kids even though they're
not written very well they act very well
Emily Blunt for the most bears a good
pop is that the only time I don't buy it
is when she smiles like Juliette pop
it's just a tough character to play I
mean she legitimately is and Andrews
does it great because she can be strict
and stern but when she smiles it feels
genuine like you feel like no she's
actually enjoying this moment she's just
enjoying it as a human being and here
it's like I buy the sternness but
whenever she smiles I'm like yeah yeah
you're not having fun you're just trying
to be Juliet's and the music throughout
this whole thing you know Marc Shaiman
who is a wonderful composer he did like
the The Addams Family movies and stuff I
made just brilliant brilliant talent
they just told them to crank it up to
like 90 billion because it won't shut up
well when when it does shut up the
scenes are weirdly boring but maybe
that's why they told him to go so over
the top because I guess there was a lot
of talk about banks and paperwork and
finances and stuff and I get for a movie
where it's like the kids go in the bath
and they're in this little underwater
world and they're singing with stuff
like that there's no adult jokes or
anything why do you want to have so much
bank talk it madness you know why do you
want to hey it's like I I give it credit
that tries to have quiet moments in it
and it even tries to have some darker
moments in there they just suck they're
not good at it you know visually it's
not bad it just I'm just thinking of the
first one the whole
Wow you know that looks nice but man in
the first one those buildings the colors
poppy even when it was like gray it's
like that gray popped it was amazing and
with this one it's like well okay that's
the technology is updated that's nice
but but it's just more the same and I
don't know for me I don't want to see
more the same I this has had years and
years of you know waiting to exist you
know another Mary Poppins story and it's
not a bad idea to go in and try to help
this family that's lost a loved one but
it's like the loved ones barely
mentioned and it's more about saving
this stupid house I do have given the
movie more credit if like if they didn't
get the house back if it was lost and
it's about moving on at least it'd be a
little different but no they just do the
early 90s cliche I was actually waiting
for like people and shades and black
suits be driving black cars because it
was just that you've seen that so much
in those little nineties movies uh so
but it sounds like I'm really really
hating this and it's actually in the
grand scheme of things it's not like
it's not an awful movie it's just
something that hit me in just the right
areas where I get really angry at it but
but even I like now it just not like
this is one of the worst movies of the
year not even close
because like I said there's good acting
there's good cinematography the songs
are good because I'm hearing a lot of
people say well they're not memorable I
that I was actually humming some of the
tunes but then I would go right back to
what they were in the first movie you
know you know think of the balloon song
at the end but then I just go into let's
go fly a guy you know it's what do you
know is nowhere to go but let's go fly
right into it and that's clearly what
they're designed to do I mean beat by
beat it's almost like they're trying to
set up a Mary Poppins formula so they
can get them out faster so they can have
pop in cinematic universes I don't know
but so they can just have this formula
you know come out so they can make them
faster and faster
I mean and it was so depressing because
the trailers were nothing but remakes
and that really is what this is it's a
remake you know that they change a few
words they change a few locations and
make some characters you know look a
little different but they're doing the
same thing and what they do add in terms
of story is really stupid and dated like
I said like you know I expect to see
like like I don't know Jonathan Taylor
Thomas or something running around with
I don't know we got to get to the bank
you know I wanted to see them go awesome
yeah like it's just so stupid so the
focus of Mary Poppins in my opinion
should be about a family coming together
and this woman who comes down and sort
of teaches them is Stern but also has
this surprising side of fun to her and
she's kind of a mystery you can't figure
her out but they bring a family closer
and and each one learns something the
key you know the kids learn more in the
first film they're supposed to be bratty
they're really not but they're supposed
to be you know that a little bit more
understanding of the father and me okay
the Michael comes and gives them the the
toughens at the end stuff like that and
the father is supposed to learn how to
be you know give it to his heir child
and give more and he's all about saving
which is good but you know it's like two
coins Michael doesn't wanna spend it on
candy he wants to spend onto this bird
lady tits just feeding birds it's just
something nice you know clearly has no
home and she's just sitting there on the
steps and it's like oh what a beautiful
thing what a tiny little thing it's a
little movie with big talent and big
visuals and big songs and big fun but
but it's supposed to be a little movie
it's not supposed to be our lives are
gonna be thrown out the window literally
we're gonna have to live on the street
we have no money unless we get it to the
bank and this big bad banker is gonna
get us and he has it out for us oh we
can just throw all our problems on the
bad guy like the first film did no
there's no bad guy so I thought for all
the repeating that they do in this movie
I thought they'd really miss the idea
about what Mary Poppins
about you know and why that's gonna hold
up why people are gonna keep watching
that over and over and it's gonna last
years and years beyond this one and I
think this movie will have its fans and
like I said it's you can show it to your
kids you can relive in the nostalgia but
all you're gonna be thinking about is it
the first one which I know it's
inevitable for a sequel and it it's
tough to make a sequel to this I can't
act like it's easy this is decades later
the first one's a classic and I I don't
know what I would do it's a tough thing
but I mean it's like you don't do this
in my opinion you try to add something a
little bit more unique a little bit more
fresh and leaping off the screen because
that's what the first film did I mean
nobody really saw anything like that
before we've seen this before
we saw it in Mary Poppins and we saw it
done better so to me this was a big
letdown but it's totally fine for little
kids people who want to relive their
nostalgia and not if you got a brain
that thinks way too much like mine when
it comes to this kind of stuff I mean
it's it's okay but like I said there's
know a lot of movies nowadays for
families try to sort of update things a
little bit they try to have you know
kind of a more adult sense of humor a
little faster a little quicker there's
just a little bit more wordplay and it's
worth playing the songs but it's the
exact same that the the first movie did
in my opinion the first film has a
little bit more of like an adult edge to
it which I know is weird cuz they're
singing around with like sheep and
horses and think about how great Mary is
but I mean if you look at the father and
the help and the wife and all that stuff
there is a little bit more to it where
this one just has honestly it just has
Jane and Michael who like I said are the
only parts in the movie where every time
they came on I'm like I love these two
they are just so good at capturing what
what those two kids were and evolving
them like literally growing them up and
I just and I they're the one things
where I'm like they were they were
spot-on but yeah everything else it's
not awful it's just the same
and if you're looking for the same fair
enough if you saw the trailer and you
were like oh that that looks enchanting
I'm really excited for this you might
like it there's there's nothing that
people can't see you know there's
nothing there's nothing insulting to
like a movie goer I should say it's more
insulting if you're a die-hard Mary
Poppins fan which I am I actually really
really love that movie but if you're
just looking for something to kind of
check your brain out go back and live in
the happy world where there's animated
fish and dogs dancing and elephants and
it's hand-drawn again which is great to
see um you'll get it and I don't think
you're gonna like it as much as the
first one I don't think anyone is gonna
be like now that was better than the
first one I'd be maybe they're out there
I don't know but it seems unlikely
because so much of it is repeated so
yeah that's about it that's my rant on
it I'm sure I went on forever on that
but I love Mary Poppins I loved the
first movie and this is just it I can
tell it's right very hard this is not a
movie where I'm like oh my god there's
it's just so lazy you know but when
you're trying to add that logic in there
there's a scene where they're riding a
bike and they put you know the kids on
it Mary Poppins and the music's like -
who do and they start riding off it's
like football Papa like this is a really
big deal like they just fit all these
people on this bike it's like five
people they have a ladder and stuff like
that it's like you know in this day and
age why you lie you're like if I went
outside thought I'd be like wow that's
really cool but in a world where you
were just swimming under water and a
woman's flying on an umbrella that's not
amazing and I feel like this movie does
not have an idea of its world or what's
amazing or what the first one was really
about but it's got some nice songs some
bright colorful imagery and a lot of
stuff that's very similar to the first
one - similar in my opinion by
is very similar and there could be
people looking for that so if you're not
looking to really be that challenged or
anything like that I mean I there is
some challenging stuff in every province
I know it sounds crazy but I mean like
look at again look at that ending look
where he's walking to the bank look
curry has to you know lose his job and
everything I mean it's it's a
challenging scene and it's done without
dialogue even feed the birds is a very
challenging song in many respects it's a
beautiful song but it's so simple too
and I really felt the things I should
have been sent simple were too
complicated the things that should have
been complicated we're too simple that
that's my overall take but it's fine to
take the kids to and it's fine to relive
your nostalgia so hopefully that helps
I'm sorry I did that I just had to get
that out there man had to get that out
it's not an awful movie it's just not my
movie it's not my Mary Poppins if you
love it and love it go ahead and enjoy
it so that's about it I shall see you
later
take care
you